Okay. Let's look at the data and compare the two distributions. The population
mean, in other words the average number of blue M&M's across all of our bags,
was 11.25. The expected value, in other words the mean of all the means we took
from our 50 random samples. Is 11.08. Notice those are pretty close. They're not
exactly the same, but they are not far off. The population standard deviation
for all 48 plates or bags was 3.49. >> Hi, it's me again. Let's recap Professor
Rogers and Professor Laraways experiment, and then predict what happened before
they tell us their result. So they took a bag of M&Ms and they calculated the
number of blue M&Ms in that bag. So this is the first bag and they put it on a
plate labelled plate number 1 and n1 represents the number of blue M&Ms in that
bag or now on that plate and they did that with the second bag and counted the
number of blue M&Ms. And they did that up to number 48, and they have 48 bags,
and they dumped each bag onto one plate. So here's our population, the number of
blue M&Ms on each plate. They found that the mean is 11.25 blue M&M's, and the
standard deviation is 3.49. From this population, professors Laraway, and
Rodgers, randomly selected five plates. And then they counted the number of blue
M&M's divided by 5, and got the average number of blue M&M's. And then they did
this 50 times. Can you believe it? So then they got 50 sample means. So now
let's take a quick quiz. According to the Central Limit Theorem, approximately
what should be the mean and standard deviations of this distribution of sample
means? So write your answer here. When you calculate these, remember you're
calculating the theoretical probability, which is based on using every possible
sample of size 5 from this population. But here they're using only 50 samples of
size 5. There are a lot more, but we can't expect professors Rogers and Laraway
to do that. That would really take forever. So calculate the theoretical mean
and standard error based on the central limit theorem.